halte ich jetzt wieder eure rolle und
heute zeige ich euch meine zehen
liebling youtube formate und die formate
ich mir gewünscht hätte dass ich sie
gefunden hätte aber leider nicht schnell
genug war und jetzt geht's los
das erste format ist michaels hass liste
wie finde ich grandios wie er sich über
alles aufregen kann ist so geil da
ärgere ich mich auch wirklich also das
format muss ich gerne hätte mich über
dinge aufzuregen und immer die shoa wie
kacke zu hauen aber das gerät geben und
er macht auch am besten das nächste
format ist harry kommentiert kommentar
ich weiß heutzutage machen das schon
ganz schön viele kommentare kommentieren
und das auch regelmäßig aber ich weiß
noch von von den jahren davor dass kelly
so eine mit der war dies eigentlich
eingeführt haben dass man das auch öfter
machen kann er hat es auch ein bisschen
verändert stellt am ende des videos
meine frage was ist nochmals ein
spannender macht und ja total empfehle
ich habe natürlich das gegenspiel panne
warmen tiert momentan kann ich auch mal
wieder machen oder also wenn ihr
momentaner habt die ihr beantworten
kriegen wollt dann schreibt sie und im
rhein das nächste format ist kids react
uhr von den feinen groß haben sie auch
mit teenager und engels und noch 1000
weiteren leuten und es ist so genial wie
kinder manche dinge einfach reagieren
dem halt die unterschiedlichen videos ob
sie die ral sind ob sie sehr emotional
sind oder sehr politisch orientiert und
die reaktion der kinder sind halt
grandios und super und ich gucke ich mir
halt echt gerne an ich werde kein
richtiger kulterer fan wenn nicht
japaner [ __ ] eines meiner lieblings
formate wer diese frau weiß es einfach
seit jahren sie mich zum lachen bringen
ich bin auch ein großer anime fan und
deswegen mag ich sie das immer noch die
schippe nimmt aber gleichzeitig seine
eigene story hat die einfach immer
weiter und die total sinnlos ist aber
trotzdem einfach so unterhaltend und ja
kultur ist super zehn arten von den
space france ja viele viele viele leute
machen zehn arten wie die unter anderem
baby und so aber die space rock sind
meiner meinung nach wie dies am besten
können und ich bin sogar der meinung
dass dies eigentlich eingeführt haben
also na klar gab es schon damals solche
videos und zehn arten sind halt nichts
was damals angefangen ist regelmäßig zu
machen und das ist so ein ding wird ich
bin einfach ein riesen fan von diesem
format große empfehlung das nächste
format ist von der lieben wickie ist
okay sie hat nämlich die youtube hotline
erfunden was auch schon wieder so ein
format ist wo ich mir denke fährt da
warum bis ich dann ist draufgekommen sie
kriegt dort anrufe von youtube oder von
leuten die mit youtube ein problem haben
und dann zum beispiel fragen wie wie
abonniert mann oder die endturniere ich
und ihr könnt ihr bei ihrem kanal
vorbeischauen und lasst ihr lieben
grüßen abonniert wie wenn ihr das format
aus hannah hart midnight run kitchen ist
eines der großartigsten format auf
youtube wenn jemand aus dem titel noch
nicht das konzept erraten hat sie kocht
dort getrunken ich weiß nicht wie es
schafft dass man eher unterhalten wird
als sich fremdschämen respekt dafür ein
feind juli wäre super mit scanner hart
sein kompagnon some day sale to face to
face and krings vom germany der
stammtisch von marie wurde wieder auf
erlebt er früher mal existiere waren
noch der robert hofmann der david alaba
jetzt macht dies im solo gang mit noch
mehr kultur mit super coolen gästen und
ich kann mir jedes mal wieder diese
stunde angucken wie sie da lava es läuft
bei mir nebenbei wie so eine
fernsehserie würde ich sagen aber mit
dem großen vorteil dass man immer wieder
zurückgeben kann falls man dann doch
nicht mitbekommen dass sie gesagt haben
liebe marie mävers tab doing this great
job ist stammtisch ein großartiges
format ist auch das format von den lokal
die einfach alles in slow motion zeigen
und ich weiß nicht warum nach ich kann
mir auch alles in slow motion anguckt
wie ein feuerzeug sieht voll cool aus in
slow motion
hätte ich nicht gedacht wird weiß ich
dank des lokals ich glaube sie machen
auch nichts anderes letzte format ist
wirklich eins meiner allerliebsten
lieblings formate lonnes trailer von
screen junkies ich weiß nicht wie sie es
schaffen sie müssen ein super team
hinter sich habe ich lach mich jedes mal
kaputt wenn ich diese orders trailer
sehen die die nicht wissen was es ist
neben ein trailer mond machen quasi die
off-stimme die darüber spricht neu und
die kommentiert das halt alles ehrlich
also alles wie es schon sagen aber hat
witzel mehr braucht man gar nicht dazu
zu sagen schaut huber ja leute das war
meine zehen lieblings format und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
vielleicht auch formate die gerne mögen
die kommentare schreibt damit ich mal
meinen youtube kosmos erweitern kann und
damit vielleicht auch andere die was
anderes außer linke challenges von danke
sehen wollen und bis dann